les journalistes et les sondeurs en
démocratie c'est un principe le pouvoir
institutionnel est séparé en trois le
pouvoir législatif c'est-à-dire celui
qui élabore et votent les lois c'est le
parlement députés et sénateurs le
pouvoir exécutif c'est à dire le
gouvernement les ministres et le premier
ministre c'est celui qui exécute les
lois et les faits respectée par la
population et enfin le pouvoir
judiciaire qui rend la justice sur la
base des lois mais à ses pouvoirs
institutionnels s'ajoutent ceux que l'on
appelle le quatrième pouvoir un pouvoir
qui est au coeur de la vie politique le
pouvoir de la presse et des médias
ce pouvoir est composé de la presse
écrite nationale au local de la radio de
la télévision et maintenant d'internet
et des réseaux sociaux
on dit que les journalistes composent le
quatrième pouvoir
parce que même si leur rôle n'est pas
défini par la constitution qui ne fait
que garantir leur liberté et leur
indépendance ils agissent sur la façon
dont les citoyens perçoivent l'action
politique les journalistes relatent
l'action des hommes et des femmes
politiques
il explique comment dans chaque parti à
l'assemblée au gouvernement dans les
tribunaux le pouvoir s'exerce en
décidant de couvrir une grève dans une
usine automobile
un débat parlementaire sur
l'organisation des rythmes scolaires ou
en se focalisant sur les nombreuses
aventures amoureuses d'un homme
politique qui pourrait être un jour
président de la république ils influent
certainement l'opinion même si personne
ne peut dire jusqu'à quel point c'est
aussi à la radio et à la télévision que
les responsables de la majorité et de
l'opposition parle à la population ce
sont les journalistes qui décide de les
inviter d'interviewer certains souvent
d'autres moins souvent de les interroger
avec plus ou moins de punch au pouvoir
d' influence des journalistes
s'ajoute celui des sondeurs sur chaque
grand sujet d'actualité les ministres et
les partis politiques de la majorité ou
l'opposition mais aussi les journaux
commentent des enquêtes d'opinion à des
instituts de sondage pour savoir ce que
pensent les français
ces enquêtes dystocie quels sont les
hommes et les femmes politiques les plus
populaires
les sondages sont comme une sorte de
thermomètre qui prend la température de
la vie des humeurs et de la confiance
des français
ces enquêtes ont une influence sur la
façon dont les journalistes commentent
l'actualité parce qu'ils ont besoin de
vendre leurs journaux et donc sur la
façon dont elle est ressentie par
l'opinion qui est re mesurer par les
sondages
c'est un serpent qui se mord la queue
les responsables politiques de leur côté
ont tendance à adapter leurs décisions
en fonction des sondages ou au moins à
adapter leur discours pour plaire à
l'opinion
ils subissent le rythme effréné imposé
par les médias qui n'est pas compatible
avec l'action politique qui nécessite du
temps les journalistes les sondeurs et
les réseaux ont donc un pouvoir très
important ils mettent de l'huile dans
les rouages de la démocratie et leur
pouvoir est critique et il leur arrive à
eux aussi de se tromper mais il reste
bien souvent en place ne sont pas
obligés de partir contrairement aux
politiques